2016 oblige les airs nous
finalement son entrée aux communes et
oui les citoyens pourront maintenant
lancé des pétitions en ligne
mais comme nous l'expliquent 1000 en
crète l'initiative ne vient pas sans son
lot de surprises la mesure a été lancée
en décembre et déjà le site du parlement
du canada compte 14 pétition
électronique
une nouveauté qui existe déjà à québec
depuis six ans et qui est populaire l'an
dernier l'assemblée nationale a reçu 71
pétition électronique soit presque
autant que les pétitions papier à ottawa
c'est le npd qui a suggéré de moderniser
le processus avec une motion adoptée
l'an dernier
les pétitions électroniques s'ajoute
maintenant aux volumineuses pétition
papier
pour être allé d'une pétition
électronique doit être créé sur le site
du parlement et obtenir l'appui d'au
moins cinq canadiens ça peut mener à des
pétitions un peu loufoque comme aux
états unis où des milliers de personnes
ont déjà demandé au gouvernement
américain de construire l'étoile noire
de star wars
une situation qui ne devrait pas se
produire ici selon le député matthew
dubé
reste que certaines pétitions peuvent
être controversé l'un de ses collègues
du npd a parrainé une pétition
électronique pour demander que le
candidat républicain dans notre umps
soit interdit de séjour au canada
jusqu'à maintenant plus de deux mille
personnes ont signé